man actually should we talk about the
gambling [ __ ] that stuff
man so first of all crazy ass
information in the last like
seven days about all that yeah so
what is it is it it's steve will do it
and other people get
a percentage of the bets that people
make
yes yeah so i don't know how coffeezilla
found this out
but he basically found the affiliate
program that rubit has so
rubid is the site that nelk was
promoting and steve will do it uses to
gamble just a crypto gambling website
like all the other ones but
the affiliate program that they have is
that um
they get they get normal affiliate
programs are like you get a certain
percentage of people that sign up like
you know for any any site that uses like
a monthly subscription
yeah something like that it's like
you'll get a percentage of or on
amazon for example you get a percentage
of anyone's purchases if they for the
next like 48 hours if they use your
affiliate link
to go to amazon yeah or for other things
it's like sometimes you get a percentage
of the
initial fee that the person uses to sign
up or whatever for gambling websites the
way it works is you get
if they use your affiliate link to sign
up with the gambling site then you get a
certain
percentage of every single one of the
your bets
the person that you help sign up their
bets so
and it it goes up depending on how much
you're getting people to sign up so oh
my god they're potentially making 15
of every single one of people's bets
and i mean i read some of these replies
to
like because coffeezilla and steve will
do it had like a interaction on twitter
and people were
they were like going at each other and
some of the some of the people that
replied were like milk fans and they
were like no dude steve i
i really think coffee zeal is right on
this one man like
you know i'm down like 10k on reuben
just this month
it's like oh my god the other part
where people you know i i read some of
that people were like just don't gamble
it's your fault it's your fault it's
like
the part that is not their fault is
i mean casinos are rigged right but
when i don't know isn't there some off
where like
the person presenting it is like staked
by the casino and is being paid by the
casino and you're essentially paying
their salary it's like it's not the same
it's not the same as just walking into a
casino that someone's like yeah i'm here
at the red rock and i love it like
that this person has like a vested like
interest and benefit
from you signing up yeah so i think
that's the part that
you know where it's shitty where people
just go
oh it's it's because the point i'm
trying to make is people are trying to
make the argument like oh it's just
it's just like any other casino you just
gamble or you don't it's like no it's
not
like this dude profits from you yeah
that's that's not just like any other
casino well and
i think part of it too is and and i
didn't see this being confirmed anywhere
but like
there's been you know basically
basically uh
it's hypothesized or whatever that a lot
of these gambling websites
bankroll their people too no i mean and
so there's actually zero percent chance
they're like there's like
there's like no downside into people
doing this they're just making money
because they're not really risking
anything by gambling
whereas the people that watch them and
sign up with their affiliate code are
risking their
savings i mean bro there have been um
because i just don't give a [ __ ] to
start the pot but like
at least like one or two people who have
confirmed the amounts they get
bankrolled to promote
certain sites and it's like i think one
of them is quoted as like a million a
month
which is [ __ ] come on dude
a million a month is crazy wait so they
so but what i mean is that like they so
they give them a million
and say use this to gamble no i think
it's just like they're just
paid right yeah like and who knows what
they stake them on top
yeah and bro uh
the thing for me is and you know
maybe maybe this is me being like a
dumbass engineer like i don't actually
know what i'm talking about but
in my mind if someone logs in
like how hard is it to
write a part of the code base where it's
like oh yeah if
user is flagged as this type of user
then make them win more
yeah yeah like is that that's really
easy to do that's why i think this whole
thing is interesting because
it's it's just like promoting uh you
know all coins and stuff like that it's
not really regulated yet i don't think
like i mean it is technically he was
saying that that's the reason why they
go to cabo to do it because it's not
legal to stream it from the states at
all like even with a vpn or something
like that you have that makes sense
that's that's why they go to cabo i
think i don't know yeah it makes sense
but um
uh what was i gonna say oh yeah so like
so they got in a tiff because steve was
like no it's coffee was like
basically these streamers are making
money on their fans losing money
yeah and he steve will do it said no we
make money on their bets it's not their
losses and he was like well
it's a casino like you're guaranteed to
lose if you play long enough
yeah so it in reality it's actually the
losses
and uh it's it's wild like
i don't know bro i don't think anyone
can argue oh
just don't gamble it's your fault if you
get addicted if you see a guy
that you sort of respect as a person and
they create content and part of their
content is like
hey man look at me winning this crazy
amount of money
some part like why it's very natural to
go like maybe i could
this dude's a regular dude like me
because it's not like they're watching
some [ __ ] like
expert poker player or like some niche
talent above them it's like this is just
a dude at his computer
that could be me yeah i think yeah but
it's also like
it's advertising it's literally
advertising yeah what do you think
advertising is
i mean yeah you can't really say you
can't really use the argument like
like i'm not promoting gambling i'm just
gambling they don't have to it's like
nobody you're getting paid to
promote this yeah what an advertisement
is and you're
winning big yeah i guess anytime you
hold up a [ __ ] ridge wallet or
whatever that's because they're hoping
your fans look at that and go i want one
now
i guess i say that to say like to me
it's even one step beyond marketing
because marketing is just like a blind
throw and it's like you might
hire samuel l jackson to be like hey i
like you know i like morongo casino yeah
like if it's a person you're like you
already subscribe to their twitch or you
buy their merch it's like you already
give them money
and then they just take it one step
further and they're like look at this
cool site i'm on
like of course they're gonna [ __ ]
give it a shot yeah i don't know i
i think the thing that bugs me is
because they play in this gray area
that's not regulated and it's not really
been flirted with before
i think it's hard for people to
articulate on the surface of their brain
like why they think it's [ __ ] up yeah
and that [ __ ] will come later like
people will figure out terms and
you know psychological [ __ ] for that and
go oh yeah
these are the things that are occurring
and people that makes them want to do it
but
it's so new that like half these kids
can't get like nailed for it really yeah
i mean just
i just i feel like for something like
this
where you know it might not be
immediately clear why it's bad yeah
i think you just have to be you have to
think like i'm making millions of
dollars every month that's too good to
be true
yeah it's too easy it's too fast money
yeah you know nothing that comes that
fast
unless you're jeff but unless you're
jeffrey oh yeah unless you build a
yeah that's the other thing it's like
the only things that really make a
million a month
are like literal titans of industry dude
like actual titans of industry yeah
it's [ __ ] up when you're like a just a
dude
drinking beer and gambling on the
internet and
you're making as much as like i don't
know
a [ __ ] like circuit board company in
china
yeah like you're what you guys output
is vastly different yeah i don't know
it's just
i mean i got to tell you did i ever tell
you about the about the prize wheel app
that i made
no okay so i mean i'm not going to act
like i'm
when i was you know whatever how old 20
what
how old is steve will do it probably
early 20s yeah so like when i was
22 i worked for that company and they
were like there was basically this app
that existed
that um it was like a it's like
basically like wheel like a
wheel of fortune sort of thing and it
had like a prize on every single
section it was like xbox ps4 or whatever
new car five thousand dollars cash and
you would spin it
and you would basically watch ads to win
spins and then you would spin it and if
it landed on it it would enter you in a
draw for that item
and this app like cruise to the top of
the app store and so we were like oh
let's just make one of these
yeah i mean it wasn't me it was like the
company that i was working for it's like
i didn't do this and i was like cool
so i made it like probably the most
ethically questionable yeah career move
i could have made at that point
is making a [ __ ] gambling prize wheel
app but i did that
i did that not proud of that and then we
got sued oh nice yeah we got a
cease and desist by like one of the main
nevada gambling companies because
they're like you can't just do that we
own this app
we own gambling you can't do this and we
were like word we'll take it down
so the mafia was like you're not allowed
to gamble pretty much or
yeah you're not allowed to have any foot
in the gaming industry just us yeah
nice yeah i mean yeah so that's the
tough part is
these these people are very young and so
their look at it it's probably you know
similar to
like how you felt you're just like yeah
it's a prize wheel like
my only focus i was like i want to get
as many people playing this [ __ ] as
possible
yeah which is absolutely scummy but it
was like for the
for the company it made sense it was
like a mobile ad company so yeah
if we got people to watch ads that
worked for us and that was my only
i was like i need to make this company
succeed so that was my only
thing and i think that's their mindset
too it's like i'm making millions every
single month i'm just going to
crank this while i can who gives a [ __ ]
what the moral
you know what the what the morals are
about this but
i mean yeah also if you're 22 making
millions i think your moral compass
is already fried yeah like you don't
have it i think the funniest thing out
of all that is like
because my first inclination is to go
look at
fans arguing with each other and
watching
uh like nelk fans fight with each other
about this was really funny like
um one of them was like
yeah but steve takes his money and he
gives it back to people
and then i think i watched like a story
or like yeah it's like a story and he's
holding up a
chain he's like i bought this dog chain
for 30 grand and i'm just dying laughing
at like i don't know
like 15 guys across america that are
like down 10k
on reuben like freaking the [ __ ] out
they can't pay rent
and then steve's just like i bought and
then a dog is wearing
their money yeah just like
damn dude it's like awful like visual on
like displacement of funds but
i don't know it's just the whole [ __ ] is
is wild
and uh the thing i'm curious about
is did faze like negotiate for some of
these kids to do it as a group
like aiden and you know
um because i i thought a group of them
were promoting gambling at a time i
could be wrong about that i don't know
but yeah it just i thought that was the
case and
maybe it's not so i mean i'll withhold i
was gonna say but
i just wonder if at any point do these
guys like give it up or
yeah do they get nailed for it i don't
know is this just one of those things
that just like that people make millions
a month
for the next five years and they're just
retired yeah
crazy